well what foolish mistakes do you see
other independent filmmakers making that
really bothers you maybe you bite your
tongue you don't say anything but it
tweaks you a little no that's a few one
that really bothers me is when
filmmakers go about things in a way that
doesn't make sense anymore like with
distribution a number of filmmakers I
know have said we need to get
distribution so we're gonna hire a rep
and a letter because it's not a lot of
advances these days from distributors
reps we're supposed to work for
percentage and started asking for
retainers $5,000 $10,000 oh no it'll
come out of my ten percent at the end
which they'll never they'll never get
that they'll never get an advance you
know we take I take ten percent I want
ten thousand upfront I'll give you
$100,000 advance never gonna happen I'm
gonna get a $1,000 advance so these
filmmakers find themselves in a position
where they feel like they have to find
$5,000 or $10,000 to pay a rep this to
sell their film to distributors when
they probably could just do it
themselves and see this Austin though or
put $10,000 toward get an aggregator
which you can approach by yourself and
put $10,000 towards that or put 10,000
other story put towards anything else
put towards you know orthodontia or
whatever so they're suddenly looking for
this money so they'll go to kick-start
know crowd fund a crowd fund money for
their rep and like we have to hire this
rep we'd $5,000 and then we'll find
distribution and I'm thinking how you
gonna pay for your delivery costs which
are five to ten thousand dollars and so
they do this and they're out there
trying to find money this way and I just
like it's so painful because I'm like
you're you're asking all your friends
and family that one favor for cash to
pay the middleman who's screwing you
that frustrates me and I've talked a few
people out of it they told me they're
gonna do that I'm like just don't do
that a few people I know have done it
and they've already done it they're
already doing it and I like I can't like
I can't really tell them that they're
doing that and I you know and then I
like do it over to their campaign you're
friends of mine do I throw my anyway and
you know do I pay their middleman it's
very frustrating yes that kind of thing
is super frustrating you know and
anything else that's that's the biggie
that comes tough that that comes out
time my mind that's the big one another
one a thing that filmmakers do sometimes
they say well we're gonna go to a small
festival first and then work our way up
to Sundance and they don't realize that
once your film is played like you know
Sundance has you know the whole thing
premiere status and that's once the
premieres so you probably are going to
get in anyway but now that you've played
the Duluth Film Festival you're you've
actually eliminated you're no longer
qualify for Sundance
you